so the two largest parties emerge from
these elections with plenty of work to
do but it's what's happening in northern
ireland that could potentially have the
biggest impact our data and economics
editor ed conway has been crunching the
numbers all day and is here with his
assessment
so many different divergent stories here
going on it's worth just taking a look
at some of them have a look at this so
we've got england we've got those
council results in england we'll also
bring you more on scotland and on wales
but let's start with northern ireland
the assembly elections here in northern
ireland they are counting and here's the
interesting thing so far have a look at
the share of the vote from those first
preference votes that we have in
northern ireland single transferable
vote system so quite complicated but we
do have a sense of how it's going shin
fein in the lead there in terms of the
biggest party in terms of share of the
vote then the dup then the alliance so
not a line party then the ulster
unionist but have a look at this over
here you can see the change in the share
of the vote compared with last time
simply only up a bit but it's the dup
who are down sharply and the biggest
winners in comparison last time around
the alliance uh party there non-aligned
party and it's worth just taking a look
at if you take these unionist parties
here they did eup and ultra unions and
shin fame the nationalist parties and
put it put them together
something else starts to emerge here so
we're looking at the alignment of
different parties and they are broadly
nationalist unionist parties they are
broadly neck and neck but it's the
non-aligned parties primarily alliance
which is starting to creep up and you
can see that over here look
the two traditional traditional wings
here down but non-aligned parties are on
the way up so a lot of people be talking
about champagne but there's another
seismic shift happening within northern
irish politics potentially in england
though the seismic shift is potentially
going against boris johnson if you look
at the color of the different councils
that we've heard from in england well it
is certainly a pattern with lots of red
there and lots of shifts away from the
conservative party if we look at
different regions
of england you see this pretty clearly
so looking all the way from the south
down through to other parts of
england and look in the south tory vote
down by seven percent seven point one
percent compared with last time in the
east down by more than three percent
down by more than two percent in london
and in the midlands and in the north as
well but here's the striking thing a lot
of focus on london wandsworth
westminster places like that going to
the labour party yes they did better in
london this is london than last time
around but everywhere else look the
south the east the north midlands they
were down they weren't up the only party
who did really well in almost every part
of england it's the lib dems you can see
there's orange bars in positive
territory so good news for the lib dems
there and if you take all of the data
that we've had from england try and do a
projection what would this mean for the
house of commons if you were going to
have a vote in the house of commons well
here it is this is our sky news
projection and it suggests a hung
parliament look at the numbers here
conservatives with 278 seats labor 271
s p 50 libdem 28 and here is the crucial
thing look at that blue bar does it get
to the 326 mark you need for a majority
in the house of commons no it is 48
seats short boris johnson's majority
gone overnight theoretically
theoretically if this were to turn into
a house of commons vote that's what we'd
see and a lot of people in the tory
party and elsewhere will be looking at
these numbers and working out
what next